All right, so the test is finished,
and now it's time to score yourself.
So if you got questions from 1 to 3 correct,
you've
probably mastered the A1 level: beginner.
If you got most questions from 1 to 6 correct,
You're probably a high beginner: level A2.
If you got most questions
correct between 1 and 9,
you're
probably at level B1: intermediate.
If you got most questions
correct between 1 and 12,
you're probably at B2 level,
or upper intermediate.
Now, if you got all the questions correct
or just missed one or two,
that would probably place you at a low C1
level, which is advanced.
So how did you do? If you didn't
get as good of a score as you would like,
don't worry, because with our
Fluent With Friends
Course, you can have fun and greatly
improve your understanding of fast
speaking natives.
Learn the vocabulary
that you actually need to communicate
confidently and master grammar in context.
So you can try it for free right now
with our 3-part master class.
Sign up now by clicking up here
or down in the description below.
Now before you go, share your score
from the test with us down in the comments
and also let me know which movie or TV
show should we create a test on next.
I hope that you enjoyed our Harry Potter
English test today.
Why not continue testing your English?
Check out this lesson next!